Traductor: Carmen Cruz
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Tal ves hayas visto
este símbolo antes,
un tatuaje temporal
o en un templo chino.
Es el símbolo del yin y el yang.
Viene del taoísmo,
una religión nacida en China
y significa mucho más
del lo que crees.
El yin es el remolino oscuro
y el yang el clara,
y cada lado tiene un punto
del color opuesto,
que nos da una pista del
significado del yin y el yang.
Todo contiene la semilla de su opuesto.
Darth Vadar tiene la semilla del bien,
y Luke tiene el potencial de seguir
a su padre al lado oscuro.
Al igual que Luke y su padre,
el yin y el yang no son
opuestos totales,
son relativos el uno al otro.
Los taoístas creen que
el universo está compuesto
de energías, vibraciones y sustancia,
que se comportan de diferentes maneras
segun el contexto
Algo puede ser yin o yang
segun muchas cosas.
Así, mientras que el trigo
que crece es yang,
cuando se cosecha, es yin.
La cresta de una ola es yang,
y su seno es el yin.
Las aldeas del lado soleado
de un valle en China
tienen nombres como
Liuyang o Shiyang,
pero la del lado con sombra,
por ejemplo,
del valle del río Yangtze
está Jiangyin.
El freno es el yin y el
acelerador el yang.
La cáscara del huevo es el yang,
el interior del huevo es el yin.
¿Crees estar entendiendo?
El yang es más duro,
fuerte,
brillante
y más rápido,
pero uno se puede convertir en el otro
o son las dos caras de la misma moneda.
Los rayos del sol son yang
en comparación a las sombras.
Lanzar la pelota es yang,
agarrar la pelota es yin.
El yang empieza una acción,
y el yin la recibe,
la termina.
El yin es el espacio
interior de una taza;
no sería una taza sin él.
El yang es la taza.
El calor del café,
sin embargo, es el yang,
y su negrura es el yin.
El yang se vuelve loco a veces,
pero también hay algunos yins poderosos,
si es que no llegan ha volverse locos.
El yin es el remolino
más oscuro, femenino,
pero contiene un punto blanco.
Y el yang es el claro, masculino,
pero contiene un punto negro.
El agua que fluye con calma
en un río es el yin,
pero cuando llega a la cascada,
es muy yang.
Los palillos de dientes son yin
comparados a un poste
La parte trasera de
una persona es más yin
que el frente.
y la parte superior es el fin del yang.
El taoísmo afirma que hay
un poder en el universo.
Es más elevado, profundo y verdadero
que cualquier otro.
Le llaman tao.
Significa el camino.
Igual que la Fuerza en
La guerra de las galaxias,
el tao tiene dos caras.
A diferencia de otras religiones
donde el poder superior es bueno,
y quizá tiene un rival malo,
el taoísmo enseña que tenemos que aprender
del yin como del yang.
Y a diferencia de las religiones
con dioses son personales,
el poder superior
en el taoísmo no lo es.
Los taoístas creen que si vive
en armonía con el camino,
una persona no tendrá que luchar
contra el flujo natural del universo.
Así, por ejemplo, si escuchas más,
discutes menos,
y estás preparado para
retroceder o reparar algo,
podrás avanzar aún más rápido.
No te preocupes en ser el mejor,
sé quien eres.
Vive simple.
Las complicaciones te alejan del tao.
El sabio es flexible, dicen los taoístas.
Aprender a usar el tao,
de eso se trata el taoísmo,
y por eso debes conocer
tu yin a partir de tu yang.